From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This summer, three people from our show, Zoe and Nadia and Angela, spent weeks at immigration court in New York City, witnessing this extraordinary thing that you might have read about or heard about happening in the hallways there. And there was one group at the center of that thing that nobody ever got to hear from. They would not talk to reporters, until now, when they've been talking to us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今年夏天，我们节目的三位成员——佐伊、纳迪亚和安吉拉——在纽约市的移民法庭花费了数周时间，目睹了你们可能读到或听说过的一件非同寻常的事，就发生在法庭的走廊里。在这一切的中心，有一个群体是从未被公众听到的。他们此前拒绝与记者交谈，直到现在，他们愿意与我们对话。
We had them on today's show. We're going to get to them in a few minutes. But first, Zoe Chace now joins me in the studio. Zoe, let's first describe what you witnessed at the courthouse.
我们在今天的节目中采访了他们。几分钟后我们就会讲到。但首先，佐伊·切斯现在来到演播室。佐伊，先描述一下你在法庭看到的情况吧。
OK, so we visited the courtrooms at 26 Federal Plaza downtown, and it's basically just a bunch of very old looking courtrooms. Normally, immigrants are coming in and out, going for their hearings in this place. It looks like it hasn't been redone since the '90s.
好的，我们去了位于市中心联邦广场26号的法庭，那基本上是一堆看起来非常陈旧的法庭。通常，移民们出出进进，去那里参加听证会。看起来自90年代以来就没翻修过。
And now, you take the elevator. You get to the 12th floor. The doors open, and it's just crowded, like three or four different kinds of law enforcement-- ICE, DHS, FBI. I saw the diplomatic security service.
现在，你乘电梯来到12楼。门一打开，就非常拥挤，有三四种不同的执法部门——移民局（ICE）、国土安全部（DHS）、联邦调查局（FBI）。我还看到了外交安全局。
Whatever that is.
不管那是什么。
Don't know. Plus reporters, a lot of photographers, activists, lawyers. Everyone's kind of huddled around one courtroom door, like a celebrity is going to come out of it. And the feeling of it, it's tense, and then it's boring. And then when somebody steps out of the courtroom, ICE surrounds them and handcuffs them and starts hustling them down the hall, and it gets very rushed, like an ER. Everyone's chasing them.
不知道。还有记者、很多摄影师、活动人士和律师。每个人都围在法庭门口，好像有什么名人要走出来一样。那种感觉既紧张又无聊。当有人走出法庭时，移民局官员会包围他们、戴上手铐，并迅速将他们押向走廊，过程非常匆忙，就像在急诊室一样。每个人都在追着他们。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Volunteer lawyers are racing down the hallway after this guy, asking for a phone number for a family member they can call for him.
志愿律师们在走廊里追着这个人，询问他家里人的电话号码，以便帮他联系。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
3, 4, 7, 3, 4, 7. Say more! I can contact your family! The guy says, I don't remember. He's pushed into the elevator.
3、4、7、3、4、7。再说一遍！我能联系上你的家人！那个人说，我不记得了。他被推进了电梯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
OK. Bueno suerte, senor. Vaya con dios.
好的。祝你好运，先生。愿上帝保佑你。
What just happened?
刚才发生了什么？
ICE picked him up. They've been waiting there all day. They know who they're coming to get. There was an ICE officer in the courtroom the entire time, texting and coordinating.
移民局把他带走了。他们在那儿等了一整天。他们知道他们要抓谁。法庭里一直有一名移民局官员，在发短信进行协调。
And just to be clear, these are people showing up at court. The government told them to. They're following the rules as part of this legal process, and then they are suddenly getting arrested in the hallway and thrown into detention.
需要明确的是，这些人是按照政府的要求来到法庭的。他们是在遵守法律程序，结果突然在走廊里被逮捕并投入拘留所。
Yeah. And we're doing so many of them here, it can feel almost routine. Between the detentions, the agents and the press and the lawyers are just standing around chitchatting about the podcasts they listen to or Lord of the Rings. And then something happens that almost reminds everyone of what we're doing here, no matter how many times we see it. It's one person's life turning completely upside down.
是的。在这里我们见多了，这几乎成了家常便饭。在拘留间隙，探员、媒体和律师们就站在一旁闲聊，谈论他们听的播客或《指环王》。然后发生的一些事，无论我们见过多少次，都会提醒大家我们在这里目睹的真相。这是一个人的生活被彻底颠覆了。
Like this one guy, his name was Luis, from Venezuela. He was around 50 years old. He'd actually entered the country legally at a port of entry. He broke no law. He was detained in the hallway, pulled into the elevator. His sister was with him, trying to follow him in. The doors closed in her face. She started jumping up and down.
就像这个人，他叫路易斯，来自委内瑞拉。他大约50岁。他其实是合法通过入境口岸进入美国的。他没有触犯任何法律。他在走廊里被拘留，被拉进了电梯。他的姐姐和他在一起，试图跟着他进去。门在她面前关上了。她开始又跳又叫。
[SCREAMING AND CRYING] (SCREAMING) Why? Why? My little brother, my little brother's a good boy. Leave me alone!
[尖叫和哭泣]（尖叫）为什么？为什么？我弟弟，我弟弟是个好孩子。放开我！
Everyone just stood there, the agents hunched over. They seem miserable. Some look down at their shoes. The sister, Anyela, eventually tracked him down in New Jersey. He's still in detention there now.
大家都站在那儿，探员们驼着背。他们看起来很痛苦。有些人低头看着自己的鞋。他的姐姐安耶拉最终在纽泽西州找到了他。他现在仍被拘留在那里。
And were the judges in on this? They're having these cases, and then people are leaving the courtrooms and being taken away in the hallway.
法官们知情吗？他们在进行审理，然后人们离开法庭就在走廊里被带走了。
We didn't know. But by the end of the summer, it didn't seem to matter what happened in the courtroom, what ruling the judges made. The agents were picking up whoever they wanted. And so we were like, what's going on with these judges? We really wanted to talk to them, but none of them would talk to us.
我们不知道。但到了夏天结束时，法庭里发生了什么、法官作出了什么裁决似乎都不重要了。探员们想抓谁就抓谁。所以我们想，这些法官到底怎么了？我们非常想和他们谈谈，但没人愿意理我们。
Well, at first.
好吧，起初是这样。
At first, but that changed because what was happening in the hallways was just part of this dismantling of the immigration court. There was all sorts of stuff happening on the inside, really in the guts of the place, that we could not see, that we didn't even know was there. And then, suddenly, the judges started talking.
起初是的，但后来变了，因为走廊里发生的事只是移民法庭瓦解的一部分。法庭内部——也就是这个机构的核心——正在发生各种我们看不到，甚至闻所未闻的事情。然后，突然间，法官们开始发声了。
Talking and saying some stuff that is totally eye-opening, and that is going to be our show today. Today we're going to hear from people who we normally never hear from, immigration judges-- the people who are supposed to make the decisions about who stays and who goes in our country. And they are saying now that is becoming very hard to do in a fair way because of the way their jobs have changed in the last few months. Some of them are being told straight up what their decision should be.
他们说出了一些让人大开眼界的事情，这就是我们今天节目的内容。今天我们将听到平时从不会发声的人的声音——移民法官，也就是那些本应决定谁能留下、谁该离开我们国家的人。他们现在说，由于过去几个月工作性质的变化，很难再公正地做出裁决。有些人甚至被直接告知他们的决定应该是什么。
Today they take us behind the curtain at the court. The robes come off. The judges get real. They talk about stuff that I have never heard was happening at all. To hear for yourself, stay with us.
今天他们带我们走进幕后。脱下法袍，法官们说出了真心话。他们谈论了一些我从未听说过的事情。想亲自听听吗？请留下来。
It's This American Life. So like I was saying before the break, for months, no judge would talk to us. Then, this summer, they started talking because of what they're seeing behind the scenes at immigration court. Nadia Reiman talked to them. Here she is.
这是《美国生活》。就像中场休息前我说的，几个月来没有法官愿意和我们谈。然后这个夏天，因为他们在法庭幕后看到的情况，他们开始发声了。纳迪亚·雷曼采访了他们。这就是她的报道。
It takes a very specific person to be an immigration judge, the kind that likes minutia, likes listening to hours of translations from Quiché to Spanish to English, just to get someone to confirm their mailing address. And obviously, you have to believe in rules. One main rule they have-- don't talk to the press.
要成为一名移民法官，需要具备非常特殊的素质，比如喜欢琐碎细节，喜欢听长达数小时从基切语到西班牙语再到英语的翻译，只为了确认某人的通讯地址。显然，你必须信奉规则。他们有一条主要规则——不要接受媒体采访。
I ended up talking to 15 judges from all over the country. Desperate times, I guess. George Pappas was one of them. He works at a court in Chelmsford, Massachusetts, close to Boston-- a pretty new judge. He's been on the bench about two years.
我最终采访了全国各地的15位法官。我想，这也是迫不得已。乔治·帕帕斯就是其中之一。他在马萨诸塞州切姆斯福德的一家法院工作，靠近波士顿，是一位相当新的法官。他担任法官大约两年了。
An average day for him until recently was usually one of two kinds of hearings-- either a lot of quick, repetitive, boring hearings just to schedule the next hearing or a full asylum case.
直到最近，他平时的日子通常就是两种听证会——要么是一连串快速、重复、无聊的听证会，只是为了安排下一次开庭；要么是完整的庇护案件审理。
There were some cases that I could not grant, so I'll go through those, OK?
有些案件我无法批准，所以我先过一遍，好吗？
Sure.
好的。
Let me go through those first.
让我先看看那些。
In those asylum hearings, a person would have to make the case that they cannot live anywhere in their home country because they're being persecuted due to their race, religion, nationality, political opinion, or the ever so squishy membership in a particular social group.
在那些庇护听证会上，当事人必须证明他们在家乡因种族、宗教、国籍、政治观点或模糊的“特定社会群体成员身份”而受到迫害，从而无法生存。
I've seen a lot of cases out of Brazil where the immigrant is saying, I'm being persecuted, and I fear for my life because the loan shark that I borrowed money from is after me. I haven't paid back the loan, and he's looking to kill me. I cannot tell you how many times I've seen that claim walk into my courtroom, and I'm just shaking my head. Why is this here?
我见过很多来自巴西的案件，移民说：“我受到了迫害，我很害怕，因为我借钱的高利贷债主在追杀我。我没还清贷款，他要杀我。”我无法告诉你我听过多少次这种申诉，我只能摇头。为什么这种事会出现在这里？
Rough going, but being chased by a loan shark doesn't make you a member of a particular social group, so you can't get asylum. Pretty clear cut. Jorge denied those cases.
虽然艰难，但被高利贷追债并不让你成为“特定社会群体”的一员，所以你不能获得庇护。界限很明确。豪尔赫拒绝了这些案件。
Kyra Lilien, a judge from another court on the other side of the country-- Concord, in the Bay Area-- she also approaches her cases with a healthy level of skepticism, a discerning ear, because, you know, that's what she's supposed to do, and some people lie.
凯拉·利连，另一家法院的法官，在国家的另一边——湾区的康科德——她也带着一种健康的怀疑态度和敏锐的耳朵对待她的案件，因为，你知道，那是她应该做的，而且有些人会撒谎。
That is something that always happens is that you do hear certain stories repeatedly and certain key details that are repeated, like hundreds of times over. And so you're just immediately thinking, how can that possibly be the case?
确实会发生这种情况，你会反复听到某些故事和细节，重复了几百次。你会立刻想，这怎么可能是真的呢？
They make you go side eyed a little. You're like, is that true? Yeah.
它们让你有点怀疑。你会想，这是真的吗？是的。
Yeah. I never felt angry about it. In my mind, there are two big reasons why you could hear the same claim from someone over and over again. One is because it's been manufactured, and it's been farmed out to a whole bunch of people, and they're all giving the same fake story. The other is because there's a pattern and practice of human rights violations in that country. And that's why everybody is giving the same story, because everybody's undergoing the same harm and persecution. So that's the challenge.
是的。我从未因此感到愤怒。在我看来，听到同样的申诉反复出现有两个主要原因。一是它被编造出来了，并被分发给了一大群人，他们都在讲述同样的假故事。另一个原因是那个国家确实存在模式化的侵犯人权行为。这就是为什么每个人都在讲同一个故事，因为每个人都经历了同样的伤害和迫害。这就是挑战所在。
So that's the job-- hearings. And the people appearing in these hearings in Kyra's court, day after day, broke down like this-- people who wanted to stay in the US, their lawyers, if they had one, interpreters, and Department of Homeland Security lawyers. And no matter what horror story from what corner of the world she hears from the bench, she keeps things calm and orderly, which is why I was so shocking when I showed up at her courthouse this summer, and she could hear the chaos right outside her courtroom.
这就是工作——听证会。在凯拉法庭上出现的这些人，日复一日，情况是这样的：想留在美国的人、他们的律师（如果他们有的话）、翻译，以及国土安全部的律师。无论她从法官席上听到了来自世界哪个角落的恐怖故事，她都保持冷静和秩序，这就是为什么我今年夏天出现在她法院时感到如此震惊的原因，因为她甚至能在法庭外听到混乱的声音。
I knew people were passing out. I knew we had to call an ambulance for someone whose husband was detained. ICE officers were hiding in the stairwell. I could see protesters outside of my window, standing in front of the ICE transport vans and trying to block them. I could see the scuffle. I could hear the drums and the honking. And I would go into court thinking everything could explode, and I have to hold it.
我知道有人晕倒了。我知道我们不得不为一名丈夫被拘留的人叫救护车。移民局官员躲在楼梯间里。我能看到窗外的抗议者，站在移民局的运输车前试图阻拦它们。我能看到冲突。我能听到鼓声和喇叭声。我走进法庭时想，一切都可能爆炸，我必须稳住。
All the judges I talked to said they were on edge about ICE now being inside the building, just outside their doors in the hall. This was a huge change. And at the same time, things inside their courtrooms began to change, too. Jennifer Durkin is a judge at a courthouse on Varick Street in Manhattan.
我采访的所有法官都说，他们对现在移民局就在楼里、在门外的走廊里感到不安。这是一个巨大的变化。同时，他们法庭内部的情况也开始发生变化。詹妮弗·德金是曼哈顿瓦里克街一家法院的法官。
Right around the time I showed up in New York, a DHS lawyer, a lawyer from the Department of Homeland Security, showed up for court. They are the side that represents the government, usually arguing to deport someone.
就在我出现在纽约的时候，一名国土安全部的律师出庭了。他们是代表政府的一方，通常主张驱逐某人。
Two things were unusual that day-- first, DHS lawyers usually appear via video for this kind of routine hearing. This guy came in person. And second, he filed a motion to dismiss the case. In fact, he said to her--
那天有两件事很不寻常——首先，国土安全部律师通常通过视频参与这种常规听证。这个家伙是亲自来的。其次，他提交了一份驳回案件的动议。实际上，他对她说——
I'm going to be making a number of motions to dismiss. I was like, what's happening?
我要提出一系列驳回动议。我当时想，这是怎么回事？
So that immediately sounded weird to you?
所以你立刻觉得这很奇怪？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Why?
为什么？
Because typically, I mean, motions to dismiss would mean that they're no longer pursuing a prosecution of the person.
因为通常情况下，我的意思是，驳回动议意味着他们不再起诉这个人。
OK.
好的。
Almost never happens. And ICE was outside. There's a series of strange motions being made. They're coming in person. It was clear that something was up.
几乎从未发生过。而且移民局就在外面。有人提出了一系列奇怪的动议。他们亲自来了。很明显出事了。
What was up was-- instead of arguing why a person should be deported, the government was like, we don't want to do that anymore. Instead, we want to dismiss the case, which, if you're the immigrant sitting there, can sound good. Like, great, I'm free!
发生的事是——政府不再争辩为什么要驱逐某人，而是说，我们不想再这样做了。相反，我们要驳回案件，如果你是坐在那里的移民，这听起来可能不错。比如，太好了，我自由了！
But the problem is you didn't win your asylum case. Your case was dismissed. And the fact that you had a pending asylum case was the only reason you could stay in the country. Suddenly, with no pending case, you have no grounds to be here. And you're standing just a few feet away from ICE who are ready to detain you.
但问题是你并没有赢得庇护案。你的案子被驳回了。而你有一个未决的庇护案是你能在国内停留的唯一原因。突然间，没有了未决案件，你就没有留在这里的理由了。你就站在离准备拘留你的移民局仅几英尺远的地方。
And the judges understood that better than the people in front of him. They were like, how can we just close this case? For what legal reason? It looked like a way to just trap people and detain them. The judges didn't know how to respond.
法官们比当事人更清楚这一点。他们心想，我们怎么能就这么结案呢？基于什么法律理由？这看起来只是引诱并拘留人们的一种手段。法官们不知道该如何回应。
So some of them called their supervisors, who are also judges, known as ACIJs, Assistant Chief Immigration Judges. Jennifer Peyton-- she goes by Jenna-- is an ACIJ in Chicago supervising 22 judges, has been a judge for nearly a decade. She was about to board a flight when her phone rang.
于是他们中的一些人给上级打了电话，上级也是法官，被称为助理首席移民法官（ACIJs）。詹妮弗·佩顿（大家都叫她詹娜）是芝加哥的一名助理首席移民法官，监管着22名法官，担任法官已近十年。她正要登机时手机响了。
One of my judges called my cell phone. And he's like, ah! They're moving to dismiss in court. I said adjudicate the case in front of you. Adjudicate the motion as you would any other motion. That's it. Like, any other motion, Judge, adjudicate this like any other motion you've received.
我的一位法官打来我的手机。他说：“啊！他们在法庭上要求驳回案件。”我说：“审理你面前的案件。像处理任何其他动议一样处理这份动议。就这样。就像任何其他动议一样，法官，像你收到的任何其他动议一样处理它。”
In other words, keep being a judge. Follow the rules and make your judgment. It seemed simple to her. Even if the government is asking for something weird, do your job like normal. In this situation, the practice is-- when one side moves to dismiss, you don't have to say yes right away. You can give the other side 10 days to think about it.
换句话说，继续做好法官。遵守规则并做出你的判断。这对她来说似乎很简单。即使政府要求一些奇怪的事情，也要像往常一样工作。在这种情况下，惯例是——当一方提出驳回时，你不必立即答应。你可以给另一方10天时间考虑。
But then, about a week after that, immigration judges got an email from the Executive Office of Immigration Review, EOIR-- their bosses who work for the Trump administration. It was about the motions to dismiss. And it said, "You don't need to give immigrants 10 days to respond. You may grant them motions that DHS is asking for on the spot." Most of the judges I talked to read this as instructing them to grant all the motions to dismiss, to side with Homeland Security. Even though the email used the word "may," judges heard it as "shall."
但大约一周后，移民法官收到了一封来自执行移民审查办公室（EOIR）的电子邮件——那是他们的老板，为特朗普政府工作。内容是关于驳回动议的。邮件写道：“你们不需要给移民10天的回应时间。你们可以当场批准国土安全部提出的动议。”我采访的大多数法官都将其解读为指示他们批准所有的驳回动议，站在国土安全部一边。尽管邮件用了“可以”这个词，但法官们听到的却是“必须”。
And that was what was concerning, that we were being told how to adjudicate motions to dismiss.
令人担忧的是，我们被告知该如何裁决驳回动议。
But just to say, I mean, those are your bosses. Doesn't it make sense that your bosses would be like, this is what we need you to do?
但说实话，我的意思是，他们是你的老板。你的老板说“这是我们需要你做的”，这难道不合理吗？
So as a supervisor, I never told my judges how to decide a case. And that is the hallmark of being an independent judge. You are resolving issues and controversy using your training and your expertise and your knowledge of the immigration laws. And I'm not going to tell you how to decide a case. And this was telling me how to decide a case. And that was what was very troubling.
作为一名主管，我从未告诉我的法官该如何判决案件。这是成为一名独立法官的标志。你利用你的培训、专业知识和对移民法的了解来解决问题和争议。我不会告诉该如何判决案件。而这却是在告诉我该如何判决。这非常令人不安。
George went to his supervisor, another judge, immediately when this all went down.
乔治在这一切发生时，立即去找了他的主管，另一位法官。
And I said, Judge, we're hearing that attorneys for the department are now coming into court, and they're asking to dismiss cases. Respondents are being arrested and put into expedited removal. Is there anything you want to tell us in terms of how you want to approach this new environment? And his response was, grant them. Grant them. I looked at him. This was a Teams video.
我说：“法官，我们听说部门的律师现在来到法庭，要求驳回案件。当事人被逮捕并被置于快速驱逐程序中。关于如何处理这种新环境，你有什么要告诉我们的吗？”他的回答是：“批准它们。批准它们。”我看着他。这是在Teams视频会议上。
And I looked at him, and I said, you said grant them? He goes, yeah. You mean rubber stamp grant them? When I said rubber stamp, he hedged a little bit. He goes, well, if they're defective. So unless they're defective, you want us to grant them? Yes. The message was clear-- don't cause any trouble. Grant them.
我看着他，说：“你说批准它们？”他说：“是的。”我说：“你的意思是像橡皮图章一样批准它们？”当我提到“橡皮图章”时，他稍微回避了。他说：“好吧，如果它们有缺陷的话。”我说：“所以除非它们有缺陷，否则你希望我们批准它们？”“是的。”信息很明确——不要惹麻烦。批准它们。
Some judges did just grant the motions, but George wanted to consider each request and rule according to each specific case. He didn't want to rubber stamp anything. So he looked up case law about how to deny these dismissals legally. And then he decided to share this info and stick it to his boss.
有些法官确实照做了，但乔治想仔细考虑每一个请求，并根据每个具体的案件做出裁决。他不想像橡皮图章一样。所以他查阅了法律，了解如何合法地否决这些驳回请求。然后他决定分享这些信息，并以此反抗他的老板。
And I made sure that that law was posted on Teams where he could see that. But it was my way of saying, no, this is the way we're going to do it. Because I would put it out there and say, folks, just so you know, here's the law on motions to dismiss. If you need to deny, here are the case laws you need to be aware of. These are the standards of review you need to keep in mind. In order to protect due process, you got to do X, Y, and Z.
我确保那些法律被发布在Teams上，让他能看到。但这是我表达“不，我们要按这个方式来做”的一种方式。因为我把它发出去并说：“各位，要知道，这是关于驳回动议的法律。如果你需要否决，你需要了解这些判例法。这些是你们需要牢记的审查标准。为了保护正当程序，你们必须做X、Y和Z。”
Is that what you said in the message?
你在消息里是这么说的吗？
Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, pretty much.
是的，差不多。是的，差不多。
Why did you do that?
你为什么要这样做？
Because I resisted. It was my legal way, internally, to challenge a directive which was wrong.
因为我反抗了。这是我在法律层面、内部去挑战一个错误的指令。
How did you feel? Were you scared to do that? Did it feel like a little strange?
你感觉如何？你害怕这样做吗？感觉怪怪的吗？
You don't know me. No, I'm not scared. I'm not scared. I'm not scared. I was angry. I was angry that we were being manipulated.
你不了解我。不，我不害怕。我不害怕。我不害怕。我感到愤怒。我愤怒的是我们被操纵了。
Jennifer Durkin from New York didn't see it the way George did.
来自纽约的詹妮弗·德金并没有像乔治那样看待这件事。
So I hadn't read it that way, but I do think others did. I was literally like, which memo?
我没那样解读它，但我认为其他人确实那样做了。我当时真是想：“哪份备忘录？”
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
I chose to assume that, of course, I would be left with my judicial independence. And that was legal decision making. And so to me, that-- I guess I had hoped and assumed that would be left untouched.
我选择假设，当然，我仍将拥有我的司法独立性。那是法律决策。所以我猜，我曾希望并假设这一点不会受到影响。
And for a minute there, that was exactly what happened. She would rule on something based on what she thought was right, which was mostly denying motions to dismiss from the government, and ICE respected that. They didn't pick up people from those cases-- let them walk out. But then, all of a sudden, ICE changed their approach.
在那一分钟里，事情确实如此。她会根据她认为正确的方式进行裁决，这主要是拒绝政府的驳回动议，移民局也尊重这一点。他们没有在这些案件中逮捕当事人，让他们走出了法庭。但突然间，移民局改变了策略。
A couple of weeks later, it didn't matter if you denied them. The people were still being detained.
几周后，你是否拒绝已经不重要了。人们仍然被拘留了。
When did you notice? How did you notice that it was happening?
你什么时候注意到的？你是怎么发现这件事正在发生的？
I want to say maybe somebody had been outside who knew I had denied a certain motion, whether it was a staff member or a security guard, and then saw them get detained, and came back in and told me-- they were like, didn't you deny that motion? And I said, yes. And they said, they took him. And so at that point, I might have looked at OPLA and I said, is everyone just being detained?
我想可能有人在外面知道我拒绝了某个动议，无论是工作人员还是保安，然后看到他们被拘留，回来告诉我——他们说：“你不是拒绝了那个动议吗？”我说：“是的。”他们说：“他们把他抓走了。”所以在那个时刻，我可能看着代表政府的律师说：“每个人都被拘留了吗？”
OPLA, by the way, is what judges call the government attorney-- Office of the Principal Legal Advisor.
顺便说一下，OPLA是法官们对政府律师的称呼——首席法律顾问办公室。
And they said, yes, to their knowledge.
他们回答说，是的，据他们所知。
What'd you say to that?
你对此说了什么？
There wasn't much I could say.
我也说不了什么。
To be clear, ICE had the legal authority to detain any immigrant whose case was pending. They just rarely used it. But now that it was happening so regularly, that brought up an existential question-- what is the point of the judge? Whether they granted the motions to dismiss, whether they denied them, it didn't seem to affect what happened to the people in their courtrooms either way.
明确地说，移民局有法律权力拘留任何案件正在审理中的移民。他们只是很少使用。但现在这种情况变得如此频繁，这带来了一个存在主义问题——法官的意义何在？无论他们批准还是拒绝驳回动议，似乎都无法改变法庭里当事人的命运。
I knew that my ruling mattered, and the way I handled the case legally matters. But in terms of the practical outcome, ICE was going to do what they were going to do regardless of my ruling.
我知道我的裁决很重要，我处理案件的方式在法律上很重要。但在实际结果方面，无论我的裁决如何，移民局都会按照他们想做的方式行事。
Right, so that's got to be a strange feeling because it's like you're saying it matters, but it matters almost like in a very intellectual way, but not in a practical way?
好的，这一定是一种奇怪的感觉，因为这就像你在说它很重要，但这种重要性在很大程度上是知识层面的，而不是实际层面的？
Yes. And it matters for purposes of appeal. It matters in terms of how that person might be able to seek redress in the future. But it doesn't matter in terms of me being able to influence, one way or the other, whether someone's taken into custody. And it was always very clear that I didn't have any influence over that.
是的。这对于上诉目的很重要。这对于当事人未来如何寻求救济很重要。但就我能够以某种方式影响某人是否被拘留而言，它并不重要。而且很清楚，我对那件事没有任何影响。
Isn't that maddening, though? Because it's not like you can influence whether or not somebody gets taken into custody, but you're literally saying this person is still in proceedings or under the protection of the court, and they're getting picked up anyway.
这不让人抓狂吗？因为并不是说你能影响某人是否被拘留，但你实际上是在说“这个人仍在审理中”或“处于法院的保护之下”，但他们还是被抓走了。
It really just felt like the walls were disintegrating around us. It felt like everything was falling apart.
这感觉就像围墙在我们周围崩塌了。感觉一切都在瓦解。
We have a big, complicated immigration system designed to answer a pretty simple question-- who can stay and who can't? And up until now, most immigration judges felt and acted like they were part of the judicial branch of government, an independent branch that just interprets and applies the laws. But they're not, not technically.
我们有一个庞大、复杂的移民系统，旨在回答一个简单的问题——谁能留下，谁不能？直到现在，大多数移民法官都认为并表现得好像他们是政府司法部门的一部分，一个只负责解释和执行法律的独立部门。但他们并不是，严格来说。
They're actually part of the executive branch within the Department of Justice. They work for the president. But till now, no administration has ever given them very direct orders about how to decide their cases. They weren't used to it, and they didn't like it. But the orders kept coming in the form of policy memos from their bosses at the Department of Justice-- a lot of policy memos, actually, that would start to transform immigration court from the inside.
他们实际上是司法部下属的行政部门的一部分。他们为总统工作。但到目前为止，还没有哪届政府对他们如何判决案件给出过如此直接的命令。他们不习惯，也不喜欢这样。但这些命令通过来自司法部老板的政策备忘录不断传达——事实上是大量的政策备忘录，开始从内部改造移民法庭。
Some targeted a problem that the Trump administration was blaming on Biden, the giant backlog of immigration cases on the books. Under President Biden, so many people entered the United States that the number of asylum cases exploded, which added to an existing backlog. The total is now more than 3.5 million pending immigration cases, with a comparatively tiny pool of judges to adjudicate them, under 700.
有些备忘录针对的是特朗普政府指责拜登政府造成的问题，即移民案件的积压。在拜登总统领导下，大量人员进入美国，导致庇护案件数量激增，增加了现有的积压。目前未决移民案件总数已超过350万，而用来审理这些案件的法官群体却少得可怜，不到700人。
Immigration judges who worked under the first Trump administration figured they would be given quotas to deal with this. That's what happened last time. Close this many cases in this amount of time, move through that backlog as fast as humanly possible. But that didn't happen, not at first, anyway.
在第一届特朗普政府下工作的移民法官以为他们会被设定配额来处理这个问题。上次就是这样。在一定时间内结清这么多案件，尽可能快地清理积压。但这并没有发生，至少起初没有。
Instead, they got all the memos, like this one, that began this way-- "EOIR adjudicators have a duty to efficiently manage their dockets. It is clear from the almost four million pending cases on EOIR's docket that has not been happening." Sick burn. This memo was like, we're going to suggest that you change the way you do asylum cases in the first place. It told the judges to look at the initial asylum application, usually the first step in this long process, often filled out by hand by people without a lawyer. And if that had anything incomplete or incorrect, throw out the whole case. Don't even hear it. It was called "praetor mission of legally insufficient applications for asylum. Here's Kyra.
相反，他们收到了一份份备忘录，比如这份，开头是这样的：“执行移民审查办公室（EOIR）的审理员有义务高效管理他们的案卷。显而易见，由于EOIR案卷中有近四百万个未决案件，这种情况一直没有发生。”真是狠狠的讽刺。这份备忘录的意思是，我们建议你们从一开始就改变处理庇护案件的方式。它告诉法官们要审查最初的庇护申请，这通常是漫长过程中的第一步，往往由没有律师的人手写。如果其中有任何不完整或不正确的地方，就直接扔掉整个案子。甚至不要听证。这被称为“合法性不足庇护申请的预先驳回”。凯拉是这样说的。
Especially with someone who's not represented by counsel, I want to hear from them. I want to meet them. I want to hear what they have to say before I adjudicate their case. I want to hear their testimony. I want to see what evidence they file.
特别是在当事人没有律师的情况下，我想听他们说。我想见到他们。在审理案件之前，我想听听他们要说什么。我想听听他们的证词。我想看看他们提交了什么证据。
This felt to Kyra like a major violation. It was telling her, don't think, don't assess. Just push this button. It felt anti-judge. Worse, it seemed to be cutting off the chance for people seeking asylum to have their cases heard, denying them the chance to present their evidence in a full hearing, denying them the due process that, as a judge, Kyra felt she should be protecting-- the due process, by the way, that is enshrined in the Fifth Amendment to the Constitution.
这对凯拉来说感觉是一个重大的违规。它是在告诉她，不要思考，不要评估。只要按下这个按钮。这感觉是反法官的。更糟的是，它似乎切断了寻求庇护者案件被听取的机会，剥夺了他们进行全面听证并展示证据的机会，剥夺了凯拉作为法官认为她应该保护的正当程序——顺便说一下，这个正当程序是宪法第五修正案所赋予的。
There was something else about the new policy memos that really annoyed the judges. The memos were very accusatory-- at the judges and the courts themselves. The overall tone was basically, you've been doing everything all wrong. Things are out of control. Now, we're going to put you on a tight leash. They felt personal.
关于新的政策备忘录，还有一点真的让法官们很恼火。备忘录非常具有指责性——针对法官和法院本身。总体的基调基本上是：你们一直以来都做错了。情况失控了。现在，我们要把你们关进紧箍咒。他们感到这是针对个人的。
They seemed like rants, ranting against the way immigration judges were handling cases and strongly pushing us into a certain direction.
它们看起来像长篇大论，抨击移民法官处理案件的方式，并强烈推动我们走向某个方向。
I heard someone refer to these PMs as the Festivus memos, as they were the airing of grievances, like from Seinfeld.
我听人把这些政策备忘录称为“费斯蒂瓦斯备忘录”（Festivus memos），因为它们就像《宋飞正传》里那样，是在发泄不满。
Yeah.
是的。
I think the tone was really significant because it didn't sound like any of them were written by someone who knew what the job was that we were doing, or understood the concerns that we would be weighing in the courtroom. It really just seems like a chip on the shoulder. It's detached from reality and completely unprofessional.
我认为这种基调非常重要，因为它听起来不像是由了解我们工作的人写的，也不像是了解我们在法庭上权衡的考量的人写的。这看起来真的像是一种偏见。它脱离现实，完全不专业。
The memos are explicitly furious with everything related to the Biden administration, saying basically that the Biden administration stacked both judge hiring and immigration court policy in favor of immigrants. And so many memos rescind Biden era policies to fix that.
这些备忘录明确地对与拜登政府有关的一切感到愤怒，基本上说拜登政府在法官招聘和移民法院政策上都倾向于移民。因此，许多备忘录废除了拜登时代的政策来纠正这一点。
They accused the judges, especially the newer ones, of being too into the immigrants, of being foot draggers and taking too long with this imperfect process that we have for ensuring immigrants get a chance to plead their case. There's one memo that was such an obvious dig at the judges, it was hard to miss.
他们指责法官们，特别是新任法官，太偏向移民，指责他们拖拖拉拉，在这种确保移民有机会辩护的不完善流程中花了太长时间。有一份备忘录对法官的挖苦太明显了，让人很难忽视。
Oh, this is a good one. Oh, god, I saw this, and I'm like, oh, you have got to be kidding me.
哦，这是一份好的。哦，天哪，我看到了这个，我当时想，哦，你们一定是在开玩笑。
Yeah?
是吗？
All right, title-- "Neutrality and Impartiality in Immigration Court Proceedings."
好的，标题——“移民法庭诉讼中的中立性和公正性”。
Can I ask you to read not the middle graph, but the one that starts, "although many immigration judges"?
我可以请你读一下不是中间那段，而是从“尽管许多移民法官”开始的那一段吗？
Oh, yeah. Oh my god. "Although many immigration judges scrupulously maintain impartiality towards both parties in immigration proceedings, there are some immigration judges who appear to believe, based on their own personal policy preferences, that exhibiting bias is justifiable in certain situations, as long as that bias is in favor of an alien and against the Department of Homeland Security."
哦，好的。我的天。“尽管许多移民法官在移民诉讼中严格保持对双方的公正，但仍有一些移民法官似乎基于他们个人的政策偏好，认为在特定情况下表现出偏见是合理的，只要这种偏见有利于外国人而反对国土安全部。”
In other words, you judges think bias towards immigrants is OK, and you keep ruling in their favor instead of fully considering the arguments from the Department of Homeland Security. It also said, quote, "Judges who would prefer to be policy advocates favoring either aliens or DHS should consider transitioning to alternate career paths."
换句话说，你们法官认为对移民有偏见是可以的，而且你们一直站在他们一边，而不是充分考虑国土安全部的论点。它还说：“那些宁愿成为偏袒外国人或国土安全部的政策倡导者的法官，应该考虑转型到其他职业道路。”
There's a lot in there.
里面内容很多。
A lot.
很多。
What parts jumped out at you when you read that?
你读到这里时，哪些部分让你印象深刻？
Oh, the alternate career path, that was a big one. Like, if you don't want to be here, just get out.
哦，“其他职业道路”，这是一个重点。就像是，如果你不想待在这里，就离开吧。
Well, I just think it's really strange for the headquarters office to say that immigration judges across the country, hundreds of us, are all ruling in favor of one side and not the other. That is pressure to rule more in favor of the side that they claim is being disadvantaged.
好吧，我只是认为总部办公室说全国各地的移民法官，我们几百个人，都在偏袒一方而不是另一方，这真的很奇怪。这是在施压，要求多偏袒他们声称处于劣势的那一方。
It's essentially, I mean, in the best light, a reminder to be a truly fair adjudicator. In the best light, you could take it as a reminder to be a fair adjudicator and respect due process for both parties. But really, what it was was a suggestion that we should be ruling in favor of DHS, and that if we're being unfair to DHS.
本质上，我的意思是，往好处想，这是一种提醒，要成为一名真正公正的审理者。往好处想，你可以把它当作提醒，要成为一名公正的审理者，尊重双方的正当程序。但实际上，这是一种暗示，我们应该站在国土安全部一边，如果我们对国土安全部不公平的话。
I kept wondering if this impartiality memo actually did change something in the way judges acted? Did it seep into the courtroom in some way?
我一直在想，这份公正性备忘录是否真的改变了法官的行为方式？它是否以某种方式渗入了法庭？
I came at this job with constant focus and an intentionality to ensure that I was considering DHS's perspective, and that I was listening, and that I was addressing their points. That's my only doubt is if I might have given DHS too much leeway
我在工作中一直保持专注，并有意确保我在考虑国土安全部的观点，并且我在倾听，我在回应他们的观点。我唯一的怀疑是，我是否可能给了国土安全部太多的余地。
So it did get in your head in a way then?
所以它确实以某种方式进入了你的脑海？
It got in my head. I don't think it ever affected the ultimate adjudication. But I do think that there are points where I let a really aggressive DHS attorney continue too long with a hurtful line of questioning because I didn't want to cut them off.
它进入了我的脑海。我不认为它影响了最终的判决。但我确实认为，在某些时候，我让一个非常激进的国土安全部律师进行了太长时间的伤害性盘问，因为我不想打断他们。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, because of trying to compensate.
是的，因为想试图补偿。
I asked EOIR about the memos, if they were trying to get judges to decide cases in DHS's favor. They said that the, quote, "numerous policy memoranda were supposed to make the judges impartial again" and undue, quote, "over 20 policies that were unfounded in law or discourage the timely completion of cases." That's it. We also asked for interviews with the director of EOIR and officials at the DOJ about all the changes the judges told us about to get the administration's side of it. They turned us down.
我问了执行移民审查办公室（EOIR）关于备忘录的事，问他们是否在试图让法官做出有利于国土安全部的裁决。他们说，引述：“众多的政策备忘录是为了让法官重新公正”，并废除了引述：“超过20项法律依据不足或阻碍案件及时结案的政策。”就是这样。我们还要求采访EOIR主任和司法部官员，了解法官告诉我们的所有变化，以获取政府方面的说法。他们拒绝了我们。
Everywhere these judges turned, they seemed to be getting the message that the job as they knew it, that didn't exist anymore. ICE was grabbing people no matter what they said. They were getting these memos where they were both pressured and disrespected. And to be honest, they'd been living in an environment where a lot of them felt under threat since the beginning of the Trump administration.
这些法官无论转向哪里，似乎都收到这样的信息：他们所知的那个工作已经不存在了。无论他们说什么，移民局都在抓人。他们收到的这些备忘录既让他们感到压力，又不被尊重。说实话，自特朗普政府开始以来，他们一直生活在一个许多人感到受威胁的环境中。
Within hours of Trump taking the oath of office, the acting attorney general abruptly fired a bunch of the immigration bosses at the DOJ-- four of the top people. This had never happened before. There was no reason given other than pursuant to Article 2, basically, the president can decide everything that happens at DOJ. It was a loud, blaring signal to the immigration section that everything would be different this time.
在特朗普宣誓就职后的几小时内，代理司法部长突然解雇了司法部的一批移民老板——四名最高层人员。这以前从未发生过。除了根据《宪法》第二条，基本上总统可以决定司法部发生的一切之外，没有给出任何理由。这给移民部门发出了一个响亮、尖锐的信号：这次一切都会不同。
Jenna is senior staff. She knew the four bosses who got fired, and it really freaked her out. Also she'd been put on this DHS watch list, this website funded by the Heritage Foundation. It calls out, quote, "America's most subversive immigration bureaucrats."
詹娜是高级职员。她认识被解雇的那四位老板，这让她非常害怕。此外，她还被列入了国土安全部的观察名单，这是一个由传统基金会资助的网站。它点名了引述：“美国最具颠覆性的移民官僚”。
Jenna's picture was there, under Targets. So she felt like she was being watched. She wouldn't wear headphones when she walked the dog after that, asked the police to come and check in on her home. She started looking at all kinds of normal things with extra trepidation, like her Teams group chat, which was your typical office group chat where a bunch of work friends talk about the job, complain about the boss, get a little snarky.
詹娜的照片就在那儿，在“目标”栏目下。所以她觉得自己被监视了。在那之后，她遛狗时都不敢戴耳机，还要求警察去检查她的家。她开始用额外的警惕眼光看待各种正常的事情，比如他们的Teams群聊，那通常是办公室里的群聊，一群工作伙伴谈论工作、抱怨老板、偶尔吐槽几句。
I was like, I need to get out of this chat, man. I just feel like-- my spidey sense was tingling. And so I sent a post.
我当时想：“伙计，我得退出这个聊天。”我只是觉得——我的第六感在作祟。于是我发了一条消息。
Why? What was going on in the chat?
为什么？群聊里发生了什么？
I don't know. It just felt like, the swiftness with the firings of Sheila and the other three, I was like, I just need to really keep my head down.
我不知道。只是感觉，由于希拉和其他三个人被迅速解雇，我当时想：我真的需要保持低调。
So she sees herself out of the group chat and finds that really soon, she gets FOMO, so she comes up with a workaround.
于是她把自己退出了群聊，发现很快就开始有了错失恐惧症（FOMO），所以她想出了一个变通办法。
I start using Signal because I'm super cool. And I open my Signal, and I start to populate it with some of my ACIJs, my buddies. The assistant chief immigration judge chat I named something like Ass Crack Instant Jokes. I don't know. It was a moment I opened it.
我开始使用Signal，因为我超级酷。我打开Signal，开始往里面拉一些我的助理首席移民法官（ACIJs），我的伙伴们。我给这个助理首席移民法官群聊起名类似于“屁股缝里的即时笑话”（Ass Crack Instant Jokes）。我不知道。我打开它的那一刻就是这样的。
Just for each initial message?
仅仅是为了每一个首字母消息？
Right, ACIJ, man. Everything needs an initial, so this is what it was-- Assistant Chief Immigration Judge Ass Crack Instant Jokes.
对，ACIJ，伙计。一切都需要一个首字母缩写，所以它就是——助理首席移民法官屁股缝即时笑话。
This becomes a good Band-Aid. The immigration judges in Ass Crack Instant Jokes do the same thing they do in Teams-- send each other memes, gossip about work, until February 14.
这成了一个很好的创可贴。在“屁股缝即时笑话”群里的移民法官们做着和在Teams里一样的事——互相发梗图、八卦工作，直到2月14日。
The Signal chat starts to pop, and one of my ACIJ buddies goes, I just got fired. And someone else says, I just got fired, too. And someone else-- me, too. And all of a sudden it was like, six.
Signal群聊开始热闹起来，我的一个ACIJ伙伴说：“我刚刚被解雇了。”另一个人说：“我也刚刚被解雇了。”另一个人说：“我也是。”突然间，就有六个人了。
Actually, it was 20-- 13 judges-in-training and seven ACIJs, people at Jenna's level. Everyone left standing started doing the math, looking at people's records in the courtroom, being like, were they more likely to grant asylum than not? Is that why they got fired?
实际上，有20个人——13名在职受训法官和7名助理首席移民法官，也就是詹娜那个级别的。每个人都开始做数学题，看着法庭上的记录，心想：他们是不是比其他人更容易批准庇护？这就是他们被解雇的原因吗？
Jennifer Durkin in New York heard about the firings, and she was like, oh crap, the people getting fired are former immigration lawyers. Sounds a lot like me. It was overwhelming for the people who were left. Here's George.
纽约的詹妮弗·德金听说了这些解雇消息，她当时想：哦，糟糕，被解雇的人都是前移民律师。听起来很像我。这对剩下的人来说是巨大的打击。这是乔治。
It was an assault. It was like an old medieval castle that was under siege. They were slowly cutting off our food supply. Now, they're cutting off our air supply. Other judges began to say, I'm resigning.
这是一场攻击。就像一座被围困的古老中世纪城堡。他们正在缓慢地切断我们的食物供应。现在，他们正在切断我们的氧气供应。其他法官开始说：“我要辞职。”
And before you think that all these judges who were feeling this way must be big asylum granters, not really. George, for example, denied like, 3/4 of his cases, but still he didn't feel safe. George packed up his office after the February firings, took everything off his walls so he'd be ready just in case. Three of the judges I talked to did this. The pressure caught up to each of them somehow.
在你认为所有这些有这种感觉的法官一定是庇护批准大户之前，其实不然。例如，乔治拒绝了大约四分之三的案件，但他仍然觉得不安全。2月份解雇事件发生后，乔治收拾了他的办公室，把墙上的一切都取了下来，以防万一。我采访的三位法官都这么做了。压力以某种方式影响了他们每个人。
I haven't been sleeping that well, and I guess I've had a lot of headaches recently and some pain in my jaw. They did X-rays, and they said, well, you have literally ground down your teeth. So mine are flat.
我一直睡得不太好，我想我最近头疼得很厉害，下巴也有点痛。他们拍了X光片，说：“好吧，你确实把牙齿磨平了。”所以我的牙齿是平的。
Oh, my god.
我的天。
Yeah.
是的。
This is all because of the stress of this happening?
这都是因为这件事造成的压力吗？
I think it's certainly been exacerbated by it, yeah.
我想这肯定被它加剧了，是的。
I don't know how to emphasize how hard these demands were on these judges. They felt completely squeezed between a duty to give the immigrants in their court a fair hearing and all that the DOJ was asking them to do. One judge told me they were feeling suicidal. Everyone talked about crying, crying at work, crying outside of work. I've never heard of so many judges crying.
我不知道该如何强调这些要求对这些法官有多么沉重。他们感到自己在“给法庭上的移民公正听证的义务”和“司法部要求他们做的一切”之间被完全挤压。一位法官告诉我他们有自杀倾向。每个人都谈到了哭泣，在工作中哭，工作之外哭。我从未听说过这么多法官哭泣。
Nadia Reiman. Coming up, an immigration judge walks into a drag club. Actually, the judge doesn't walk into a drag club. He does not talk to the owner. That is the problem. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
纳迪亚·雷曼。接下来，一名移民法官走进了一家变装俱乐部。其实，法官并没有走进变装俱乐部。他没有和老板交谈。这就是问题所在。这在一分钟后节目继续时讲，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- The Hand That Rocks the Gavel. Nadia Reiman's story about immigration judges and the things that they are witnessing inside immigration court these days continues.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——《握住木槌的手》。纳迪亚·雷曼关于移民法官和他们这些天在移民法庭目睹的事情的故事继续。
Its Fourth of July weekend. Jenna, the boss judge, decides to go out with her family to a summer home they have on a river. It's nice, and it's rural. She leaves her government phone charging and isn't looking at it-- really wants to unplug. But at the end of the day, she gets tempted.
是国庆节周末。作为主管法官的詹娜决定和家人去他们在河边的一个避暑小屋。那儿很棒，很乡村。她让政府手机充电，并不看它——真的想关机断网。但在一天结束时，她受到了诱惑。
Let me just do a quick little scroll and just make sure there's nothing I need to really worry about. So I turn on my phone, and I do a scroll, and I see an email. The subject is, Notice of Termination dash Peyton. It's from Director Owen. And the email says, please see the attached.
让我快速浏览一下，确保没什么我需要担心的事情。所以我打开手机，浏览了一下，看到了这封邮件。主题是：终止通知 - 佩顿。来自奥文主任。邮件说：请参阅附件。
Wait, what was it? What was the attachment?
等等，是什么？附件是什么？
Oh, hang on. I can read it to you. It's all of three sentences. I probably have it memorized because it was so short.
哦，等等。我可以给你读。总共三句话。我可能已经背下来了，因为它太短了。
Wow.
哇。
Hang on, let me go back and find it. "Dear Judge Peyton, this notice serves to inform you that, pursuant to Article II of the Constitution, the attorney general has decided to remove you from your position as an accepted Service Assistant Chief Immigration Judge with the United States Department of Justice Executive Office for Immigration Review. Your removal is effective today. You are required to return all government property by the end of the day. Sincerely, Sircy Owen, acting director, EOIR."
等等，让我回去找一下。“亲爱的佩顿法官，本通知旨在通知您，根据宪法第二条，总检察长已决定免除您美国司法部执行移民审查办公室被接受的助理首席移民法官职务。您的免职即日起生效。您需要在本日结束前归还所有政府财产。此致，瑟西·奥文，代理主任，EOIR。”
Jenna had been on the bench for almost nine years. EOIR didn't say why they fired her.
詹娜担任法官已近九年。EOIR没有说明为什么要解雇她。
A week after Jenna got fired, George in Massachusetts was approaching the end of his two year probationary period. That's the time before judges are made permanent, which is usually not even a question. Basically, everyone gets made permanent. The first batch of judges who got fired back in February, though-- it happened right at the end of their two-year probationary period. So George knew what was coming.
詹娜被解雇一周后，马萨诸塞州的乔治接近他两年试用期的尾声。那是法官转为永久任命之前的时间，通常甚至不成问题。基本上，每个人都能转为永久。不过，二月份被解雇的第一批法官——发生时正值他们两年试用期的最后阶段。所以乔治知道接下来会发生什么。
Yeah, it was frightening-- July 11 at about 3:30.
是的，很吓人——7月11日下午3:30左右。
Really? You predicted, like, down to around 3:30?
真的吗？你预测得那么准，就在3:30左右？
Yeah, yeah, they're to the T. I wish it was a lottery because I could retire now.
是的，是的，分秒不差。我希望这是彩票，因为那样我现在就可以退休了。
Jennifer Durkin from New York got fired that exact same way-- short letter, end of the day, also was at the end of her two-year probationary period. And Kyra was also at the end of her two years. And out of all the firing stories I heard, hers was the nuttiest.
来自纽约的詹妮弗·德金被解雇的方式完全一样——简短的信，一天结束时，也正值她两年试用期的末尾。凯拉也处于两年的末尾。在所有我听到的解雇故事中，她的最离谱。
I was on the record in the middle of a hearing, and I got the email. When I saw the email that I've been dreading for five or six months when I saw it come in through my Outlook account, I just said, I'm very sorry. We're going to have to go off the record for a moment. And we went off the record. I looked at it. I made sure I was reading it correctly.
我当时正在审理中，正在记录在案，这时我收到了邮件。当我看到那封我担心了五六个月的邮件通过我的Outlook账户传进来时，我只是说：“非常抱歉。我们得暂时休庭，停止记录。”我们停止了记录。我看着它。我确认我读对了。
It was only three lines long, and it said I needed to turn in my laptop and badge immediately and leave. And I told the parties that I had just been fired--
它只有三行长，说我需要立即上交笔记本电脑和工牌并离开。我告诉双方当事人，我刚被解雇了——
Oh, my god.
我的天。
--and I'm not going to be able to conclude the hearing. And both the attorneys, both for DHS and respondent's counsel said, what? Are you joking? And I said, I'm not joking.
——而且我将无法完成这次听证。两位律师，国土安全部的律师和当事人的律师都说：“什么？你在开玩笑吗？”我说：“我不是在开玩笑。”
That's wild. So there's an immigrant and their lawyer sitting there looking at you?
这太疯狂了。所以有一个移民和他们的律师坐在那里看着你？
Yeah. Yeah, and for better or for worse, that lawyer then blasted out something on a listserv that I started in the following days. People started sending me screenshots of this email he'd sent out. And it was, y'all, this is wild. IJ Lilien was fired on the bench, and this is what happened. And so that was also a little-- it just was so public in that way.
是的。是的，不管好坏，那个律师随后在一个我后来加入的列表服务中发出了什么东西。人们开始发给我他发出的那封邮件的截图。上面写着：“各位，这太疯狂了。利连法官在法官席上被解雇了，事情就是这样。”所以那也有点——以那种方式太公开了。
I was physically trembling. And always in court, disturbing and upsetting things happen. Disturbing and upsetting facts come to light. And it is the job of the judge to maintain the dignity and decorum of the court and to show respect for the parties. And that's just where I went.
我当时在身体发抖。在法庭上，总会发生令人不安和沮丧的事情。令人不安和沮丧的事实会浮出水面。而法官的职责是维护法庭的尊严和礼仪，尊重当事人。这就是我当时所处的境界。
And I told them what had happened. And I said, I need to get back on the record. And we did. And I said, my apologies to the parties. I'm not going to be able to hear this case today. The court will reach out to you with a new hearing date. And to respondent's counsel, can you please explain to the respondent that we're not able to have a hearing today, and I do apologize for that. And then we disconnected. My visceral feeling when I got that message was relief because I had been living on a knife's edge for months.
我告诉了他们发生了什么。我说：“我需要继续记录。”我们照做了。我说：“向双方道歉。我今天无法审理此案。法院会联系你们重新安排听证日期。对于当事人的律师，请您向当事人解释我们今天无法进行听证，我为此表示歉意。”然后我们断开了。当我收到那个消息时，我内心的感觉是解脱，因为我已经像走钢丝一样过了好几个月了。
Almost all of the 15 judges I talked to no longer work at the DOJ. A few retired when they were given the option, but most were just fired. None of them have real answers about why, beyond those short letters. Some have sued.
我采访的15位法官中，几乎所有人都不再在司法部工作了。一些人在获得选择权时选择了退休，但大多数只是被解雇了。除了那些简短的信件，他们都没有关于原因的真正答案。有些人已经提起诉讼。
We asked EOIR about all these firings. They declined to comment. Under Biden, a small number of judges were also let go, and that was seen as political and scandalous then to many Republicans. It's fair to say, though, that the kind of mass reshaping that's happening now is on a different level.
我们询问了EOIR关于所有这些解雇的事，他们拒绝评论。在拜登领导下，也有少数法官被解雇，当时这对许多共和党人来说被视为政治和丑闻。然而，公平地说，现在正在发生的这种大规模重塑处于不同的层面。
Since the Trump administration began, more than 60 judges have been let go, and around 40 resigned, which means, that out of the roughly 700 judges we had pre-Trump, about 100 are gone. Recently, the administration has been talking about bringing in 600 military lawyers to serve as temporary judges to speed through the backlog. Sitting judges we've talked to say they're worried that these new judges won't get enough training, so they'll just rubber stamp anything the administration wants.
自特朗普政府开始以来，有超过60名法官被解雇，约40人辞职，这意味着，在特朗普之前我们拥有的约700名法官中，大约100人已经离职。最近，政府一直在谈论引入600名军事律师作为临时法官，以加快积压案件的处理速度。我们采访过的在职法官说，他们很担心这些新法官不会得到足够的培训，所以他们只会像橡皮图章一样批准政府想要的任何东西。
If all this sounds like the Trump administration is trying to reduce the power of the immigration court and bring it to heel, well, some people think that's way overdue. We talked to Scott Mechowski, former deputy head of ICE New York. He was the removal officer for 27 years.
如果这一切听起来像是特朗普政府试图削弱移民法庭的力量并使其服从，那么，有些人认为这早就该做了。我们采访了前纽约移民局副局长斯科特·梅霍夫斯基。他担任驱逐官27年。
His job was to find immigrants who were here illegally and deport them. And the way he sees it, the main thing that got in his way-- immigration courts. My colleague Zoe Chace talked to Scott.
他的工作是寻找非法滞留在这里的移民并将他们驱逐出境。在他看来，阻碍他工作的主要因素是——移民法庭。我的同事佐伊·切斯采访了斯科特。
OK, first off, man, it could have been three, four, five years before somebody has a fucking hearing. And then they go to court, and a judge will be like, well, do you have an attorney? No. OK, we're going to adjourn for nine months until you find an attorney, right?
好的，首先，伙计，某人可能在开庭前得等上三、四年、五年。然后他们去法庭，法官会问：“你有律师吗？”“没有。”“好的，我们 adjourn（休庭）九个月，直到你找到律师，对吧？”
They get an attorney, then they go, you know what? I want to withdraw this counsel. OK, I'll give you another nine months. There's cases that have been fucking re-calendared for years, for years, right? And the American people don't understand that.
他们找了律师，然后他们又说：“你知道吗？我想撤换律师。”“好的，我会再给你九个月。”有些案子甚至被重新列入排期好几年，好几年，对吧？而美国人民根本不明白这一点。
Yeah, they're like, come back February 3, 2029 or something like that.
是的，他们就像是，“2029年2月3日再回来”什么的。
Yes, Zoe, that's exactly the issue. Now, when you're being detained, there is none of that shit. No one's going to leave you in custody for a year and a half, two years before your next hearing date. You know I mean? Now, you could fiddle fuck around and keep going, I appeal. I do this, I want to do that and stay in custody, which they do.
是的，佐伊，这正是问题所在。现在，当你被拘留时，就没有那些狗屁事了。没有人会在你下一次开庭日期之前把你关押一年半、两年。你明白我意思吗？现在，你可以到处捣乱，不停地说，“我上诉，我这样做，我想做那个”，并留守在拘留所里，他们确实这么做。
Wait, so can I just say what I feel like? What you're saying is making me think is it's easier just to do the whole process, as much as the process as you can, in a detention setting--
等等，我可以只说说我的感受吗？你所说的让我觉得，在拘留环境下进行整个过程，尽可能多地进行流程，会更容易——
Yep.
是的。
--because then you have control over the whole thing, and the person will actually be removed at the end.
——因为这样你就能完全掌控整个事情，而那个人最终会被确实驱逐。
Zoe, bingo, bingo.
佐伊，宾果，宾果。
So that's why we're seeing what we're seeing?
所以这就是为什么我们看到现在的这些情况？
That's exactly why. Look, the only mechanism-- and I'll tell you again-- to ensure removal is detention. I know it sucks to hear that, right?
这正是原因所在。看，唯一的机制——我会再次告诉你——确保驱逐的是拘留。我知道听到这个很糟糕，对吧？
Say you're in court and you lose your case, Scott says. You're deportable. But they don't just throw you on a plane. You walk out of the courtroom. The government sends you a letter.
你说你在法庭上输了官司，斯科特说。你是可驱逐的。但他们不会只是把你扔上飞机。你走出法庭。政府给你寄了一封信。
Dear so-and-so, you've been ordered deported on this date. Please show up at my office in 30 days with one bag weighing no more than 44 pounds for your removal. As you can imagine, most people don't show up. But if they were in detention, Scott says, easy-- ICE can just deport them.
“亲爱的某某，你已被命令在某日期被驱逐。请在30天内带着不超过44磅的一个行李箱到我的办公室报到。”你可以想象，大多数人不会报到。但如果他们被拘留了，斯科特说，很简单——移民局可以直接把他们驱逐出去。
So he says, anyone with an immigration case, let's just get them into detention and do the whole thing from there. The way former New York City immigration Judge Jennifer Durkin sees this, this is exactly what the memos and policy changes are adding up to.
所以他说，任何有移民案件的人，让我们直接把他们拘留起来，从那里进行整个过程。以纽约市前移民法官詹妮弗·德金的角度来看，这正是备忘录和政策变化所要达到的目标。
Detention is the point. I mean, they'll say it's to efficiently and orderly, I guess, decide the cases. But I think detention and the constraints that places on people is the point.
拘留才是重点。我的意思是，他们会说这是为了高效、有序地决定案件，我猜。但我认为拘留以及它给人们带来的限制才是重点。
Because then people will be getting out.
因为那样人们就会离开了。
Take orders, yeah.
听从命令，是的。
They'll self-deport because being in detention is terrible, even in the best of circumstances. Or if they don't, the government will do the job for them.
他们会自我驱逐，因为待在拘留所里太可怕了，即使在最好的情况下也是如此。或者如果他们不走，政府就会帮他们完成任务。
I spent a lot of time while I was reporting this story trying to put together the puzzle pieces and see what this all adds up to. What does the Trump administration want the immigration courts to be? In the end, I don't think it's that complicated.
在报道这个故事时，我花了很多时间试图拼凑这些拼图，看看这一切意味着什么。特朗普政府希望移民法庭成为什么样？最终，我不认为这很复杂。
Trump made a promise of mass deportations, so he's finding a way for the courts to not get in the way. His people are good at this sort of thing-- pulling any lever available to them, showing every institution exactly where their power ends. And if judges are the obstacle, like wrenches in the gears of the mass deportation machine, that's no problem. There are a few ways to put pressure on a judge to co-sign on deportations.
特朗普做出了大规模驱逐的承诺，所以他正在寻找一种方法让法院不挡路。他的人擅长这种事——利用他们能用的任何杠杆，向每个机构展示他们的权力到底在哪儿结束。如果法官是障碍，就像大规模驱逐机器齿轮里的扳手，那没问题。有几种方法可以向法官施压，让他们在驱逐令上签字。
You can change procedure, the rules of the court. That's what the memos did. You can intimidate-- the firings, the threat of more firings coming up every few weeks. And there's one more cleaner, more direct and effective way if you run the DOJ-- change the case law, set new legal precedents, precedents that judges now have to follow, which is exactly what Trump's DOJ has been doing.
你可以改变程序，即法院的规则。备忘录就是这么做的。你可以恐吓——解雇、每隔几周就出现的更多解雇威胁。如果你掌管司法部，还有一种更清洁、更直接、更有效的方法——改变判例法，设定新的法律先例，法官现在必须遵循这些先例，这正是特朗普的司法部一直在做的。
Since March, decisions have been coming fast and furious out of the Board of Immigration Appeals, setting new legal precedents for how things will work now. For example, the Trump administration has narrowed the kinds of cases that are eligible for asylum and made it much harder to prove them. Also maybe the biggest change-- any undocumented person, even if they have a legal case in process, even if they've been in the US for a decade, they can now be detained indefinitely.
自三月份以来，裁决从移民上诉委员会蜂拥而出，为现在的工作方式设定了新的法律先例。例如，特朗普政府缩小了有资格获得庇护的案件范围，并使证明这些案件变得更加困难。还有可能是最大的变化——任何无证件的人，即使他们的案件正在处理中，即使他们已经在美待了十年，现在都可以被无限期拘留。
Before, you could post bond and get out while you fight your case. Now, no more bond. Just detention, nothing but detention, potentially for millions of people. And in a big-picture way, there's no one left at the top to disagree with all these big changes. Because a month into the new administration, the DOJ removed nearly half the judges on the Board of Immigration Appeals-- everyone who'd been appointed under Biden, pretty much. So all this new case law now matches the Trump policy objectives almost completely. And the judges, of course, have to adhere to it.
以前，你可以交保释金，在打官司期间离开。现在，没有保释金了。只有拘留，除了拘留什么都没有，可能涉及数百万人。从宏观角度看，高层没有人剩下可以反对所有这些重大变化。因为在新政府上台一个月后，司法部撤换了移民上诉委员会近一半的法官——几乎所有拜登时代任命的人。所以现在所有这些新的判例法几乎完全符合特朗普的政策目标。当然，法官们必须遵守。
So say this all works out the way the Trump administration seems to be hoping, and we start detaining more people and having them do their entire legal process from detention. What does that actually look like? What's the result when you put all these cases inside that used to be outside?
所以假设这一切都像特朗普政府似乎希望的那样成功，我们开始拘留更多的人，并让他们在拘留期间走完整个法律程序。那到底是什么样子的？当你把所有这些本来在外部处理的案件都放进内部时，结果是什么？
I want to tell you about one person who had to do this, had to navigate this new world of detain now, figure it out from there. It's a case from where we started-- New York. And the reason I want to take you through his story is because it illustrates the positive side of what the Trump administration is doing. His case speeds to a quick resolution, and it also illustrates the downside, which I'll get to.
我想告诉你一个不得不这样做的人，不得不适应这个“现在就拘留，从那里弄清楚”的新世界的人。这是我们开始的地方的一个案例——纽约。我之所以想带你了解他的故事，是因为它展示了特朗普政府正在做的事情的正面。他的案件迅速得到解决，但也展示了阴暗面，我稍后会讲到。
I'm going to call this person David. He's an asylum seeker. David's from Ecuador. I talked with him on the phone. When I asked him about his life in New York, which was only five months, listen to the feeling. You can hear him smiling.
我要叫这个人“大卫”。他是一名寻求庇护者。大卫来自厄瓜多尔。我在电话里和他聊过。当我问他关于在纽约的生活时，那只有五个月，听听那种感觉。你能听到他在微笑。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
David loved New York, like many gay men before him. He was happy here. Back in Ecuador, he actually ran this drag club.
大卫喜欢纽约，就像许多在他之前的男同性恋者一样。他在那儿很开心。在厄瓜多尔时，他实际上经营过这家变装俱乐部。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's Time to Get it On-- that's the name of the place.
“是时候开始了”（It's Time to Get it On）——这就是那个地方的名字。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Because he says, when you do drag, you get on your heels. You get on your wig and whatever else you want to get on. David told me that, in Ecuador, it's not an automatic death sentence to be gay like it is in some places. There's gay marriage, for example.
因为他说，当你做变装时，你要穿上高跟鞋。你要戴上假发，穿上任何你想穿的东西。大卫告诉我，在厄瓜多尔，作为同性恋并不会像在某些地方那样自动被判死刑。比如有同性婚姻。
But for him, it got really bad there because he had dated a politician who was closeted. After they broke up, he came after David. David thinks he sent cops to harass him, smashed up his car. So David moved to the capital, Quito, to get away from this guy. And he says the politician and his people followed him-- beat him up so badly he woke up at the police station hours later, not knowing how he got there.
但对他来说，情况在那里变得非常糟糕，因为他曾和一位在柜里的政治家约会。他们分手后，那个人开始针对大卫。大卫认为是他派警察去骚扰他，砸了他的车。所以大卫搬到了首都基多，想躲开这个家伙。他说那位政治家和他的手下追踪到了他——把他打得很惨，以至于他几小时后在警察局醒来，不知道自己是怎么到那里的。
This was the moment that David thought, I'm not safe anywhere in Ecuador. He decided to leave. And he did everything our government told him to do in order to come here the right way. He entered the United States without breaking any laws.
那一刻大卫觉得：我在厄瓜多尔哪里都不安全。他决定离开。他做了我们政府告诉他的一切，以便以正确的方式来到这里。他进入美国时没有触犯任何法律。
He crossed at a border checkpoint, which is legal. He used the official government app to schedule his crossing, which is how we told immigrants to do it at that time. It meant he waited for months till it was his turn. And once he was here, he had permission to work. And now he was going through the required process to stay. It was all above board.
他在边境检查站过境，那是合法的。他使用政府的官方应用程序来安排他的过境，这是当时我们告诉移民这样做的方式。这意味着他等了几个月才轮到他。一旦他来到这里，他就有了工作许可。现在他正在走要求的流程以便留下来。一切都是公开透明的。
David has a sister who lives in New York. He's 33, number six out of nine siblings. He decided to go stay with her, live his New York dream. And he got a job he liked, doing marketing for a supermarket chain. And he met someone.
大卫有个姐姐住在纽约。他33岁，九个兄弟姐妹中排行第六。他决定去和她住在一起，实现他的纽约梦。他找到了一份他喜欢的工作，为一家超市连锁做市场营销。他还遇到了一个人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
David says, the first thing he remembers is he asked me if I could speak English, and I was like, nope. The man that would become his boyfriend didn't let that stop him. He sat on the sidewalk with David and Google Translate, and they talked for hours.
大卫说，他记得的第一件事是那个人问他会不会说英语，他当时说：不会。那个后来成为他男朋友的人并没有因此放弃。他和坐在人行道上的大卫一起用谷歌翻译聊了几个小时。
David was like, he's cute. They started dating. And then David gets his first immigration court date. It's a routine scheduling hearing at the courthouse downtown on June 4. He wants to be prepared. So ahead of time, he goes to a law clinic, gets help with his asylum application, makes two copies-- one for himself, one for the judge. But he was watching the news and started to see that ICE was picking up people in the courthouse. I was afraid to go, David says, but my boyfriend insisted. He was like, you want to do things the right way.
大卫当时想：他很可爱。他们开始约会。然后大卫收到了他的第一次移民法庭开庭日期。那是6月4日在市中心法院的一次例行排期听证会。他想做好准备。所以提前，他去了法律诊所，在庇护申请上获得了帮助，做了两份副本——一份给自己，一份给法官。但他一直在看新闻，开始看到移民局在法院大楼里抓人。“我不敢去，”大卫说，“但我男朋友坚持。他当时说：你想以正确的方式做事。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So David wakes up the morning of his hearing, puts on his suit to go to work. He was hoping, if it all went well, it would just be a quick thing, and he'd go to work right after. And he heads downtown.
所以大卫在听证会那天早上醒来，穿上西装去上班。他希望，如果一切顺利，那只是个小事情，他之后就能去上班。于是他前往市中心。
He says there were bad signs along the way. Like at breakfast, they wouldn't serve him and his friends. It took forever. And then he dropped all these napkins. They blew everywhere in the wind. It was like a dark omen.
他说这一路上有不祥之兆。比如早餐时，他们不服务他和他的朋友。花了很长时间。然后他不小心掉了一堆餐巾纸。它们被风吹得到处都是。就像一个黑暗的预兆。
When he finally got to court, he sat in the waiting room, went in front of the judge when it was his turn, offered the two copies of his asylum application, and the judge didn't take them. He heard the DHS attorney ask for his case to be dismissed. He heard the judge agree to the dismissal. Because he'd been watching the news, he knew what that meant. As soon as he walked out of the courtroom, ICE officers cuffed him and walked him to the elevator.
当他最终到达法庭时，他在等候室里坐下，轮到他时，走到了法官面前，提供了他的两份庇护申请副本，而法官没有收。他听见国土安全部的律师要求驳回他的案子。他听见法官同意驳回。因为他一直在看新闻，他知道这意味着什么。他一走出法庭，移民局官员就给他戴上了手铐，把他带到了电梯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I went into shock, he says. All I did was walk. I didn't know what was going to happen, what was happening. I didn't feel hot or cold or sadness or happiness, just nothing. They cuffed my waist, my feet, my hands, and they took me down to the parking lot.
“我陷入了震惊，”他说，“我所做的只是走。我不知道会发生什么，不知道正在发生什么。我感觉不到热、冷、悲伤或快乐，什么都没有。他们锁住了我的腰、脚和手，把我带到了停车场。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I tried every time I could to tell my boyfriend what was going on, David says. And the last message that I sent him, that he still can't forget, is when I texted him, they're taking me.
“我每次有机会都会试图告诉我的男朋友发生了什么，”大卫说。而他最后发给他的那条信息，他至今无法忘记，是他发短信说：“他们带走了我。”
David got held on the 10th floor at 26 Federal Plaza in New York for three days. There's a holding cell there that's supposed to be temporary, but this summer has become the de facto detention center. And all reports out of there say that it is rank. David says it was so packed in there you could only sleep standing up.
大卫在纽约联邦广场26号的10楼被关押了三天。那里有个拘留间本应是临时的，但今年夏天已成了事实上的拘留中心。所有来自那里的报告都说那里恶臭不堪。大卫说里面挤满了人，你只能站着睡觉。
David then got sent to a detention center in Newark, New Jersey. He would be there for about 10 days. While he was there, he kept asking ICE to let him do a credible fear interview, which is one of the first steps in the asylum process. He was like, I had my application. I'm afraid to return to Ecuador.
大卫后来被送往新泽西州纽瓦克的拘留中心。他在那里待了大约10天。当他在那里时，他一直要求移民局让他进行一次“可信恐惧面试”，这是庇护过程中的第一步。他说：“我有申请。我很害怕回厄瓜多尔。”
He says the ICE officers would just stare at him and not say anything back, or they would tell him to do it in writing, which he did. There was no response. He never got an interview-- just to say he's supposed to get one as soon as he asks. ICE is supposed to facilitate it, but that doesn't mean they always do.
他说移民局官员只是盯着他不回话，或者让他们书面申请，他也照做了。没有回应。他从未获得面试机会——只需说他一旦要求就应该得到面试。移民局理应提供便利，但这并不意味着他们总是这么做。
And this, judges and immigration lawyers told me, is one of the biggest problems with having people pursue their cases from inside detention. ICE sometimes ignores the legal process, and the detainees don't have much access to a lawyer to force them to follow it. We asked ICE about all of David's claims, including how they ignored his request to get a credible fear interview. They didn't respond.
法官和移民律师告诉我，这就是让人在拘留中追求案件处理的最大问题之一。移民局有时会无视法律程序，而被拘留者没有多少律师能强制他们遵守。我们询问了移民局关于大卫的所有主张，包括他们如何忽视他进行可信恐惧面试的请求。他们没有回应。
One day in June, ICE put David on a flight. He didn't know where he was going, and no one told him. He was brought to a detention center in Louisiana. Lots of people with cases from New York get sent down south to Louisiana and Texas, where judges are extremely strict; the case law is harsher against detainees, and there are more detention centers.
六月的一天，移民局把大卫送上了飞机。他不知道要去哪里，没人告诉他。他被带到了路易斯安那州的一个拘留中心。很多在纽约有案件的人被送往南方的路易斯安那州和得克萨斯州，那里的法官极其严格；判例法对被拘留者更苛刻，而且拘留中心更多。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There are so many people there, David says, so many. Tons of bunk beds in one giant room, and it was super dirty. It was unbearably hot, he says. Everyone hung out in their underwear because it was so hot.
“那里有很多人，”大卫说，“太多了。一个巨大的房间里有成吨的上下铺，而且超级脏。热得无法忍受，”他说，“每个人都只穿内衣待着，因为太热了。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I was ready to put up with New Jersey, put up with that as long as I needed to, David says. But Louisiana, I didn't want to be in Louisiana one more second.
“我准备好忍受新泽西，忍受任何我需要忍受的，”大卫说。“但路易斯安那，我不想在那里多待一秒钟。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He says he was ready to self-deport, but he didn't even think he'd have the right to do that. Two days later, ICE put him on another flight. Again, he didn't know where he was going. He found out when he landed. He was back in Ecuador.
他说他准备好“自我驱逐”了，但他甚至不认为自己有权这样做。两天后，移民局又把他送上了飞机。同样，他不知道要去哪儿。落地时他才发现。他又回到了厄瓜多尔。
As soon as he got to Ecuador, David went into hiding. He barely leaves his house, does all of his work from his phone or computer. He's scared his ex-boyfriend, the politician, will know where he is, which is why we can't tell you where in Ecuador he is, or his real name, because David is scared for his life now that our government returned him to the one country where he felt he was in the most danger.
大卫一到厄瓜多尔就躲了起来。他几乎不出家门，所有的工作都在手机或电脑上完成。他害怕那个身为政治家的前男友知道他在哪里，这就是为什么我们不能告诉你他在厄瓜多尔哪里，或者他的真名，因为大卫现在很为自己的生命担心，因为我们的政府把他遣返回了那个他觉得最危险的国家。
David's lawyer told me David's asylum case, pretty solid. He was fleeing a government that was actively trying to harm him, and he has documentation showing what happened. He's exactly the type of case, she thinks, the law is designed to protect. And at the very least, it's a case that deserves a hearing in front of a judge to figure out what's right.
大卫的律师告诉我，大卫的庇护案，“相当扎实”。他是在逃离一个积极试图伤害他的政府，而且他有记录证明发生了什么。她认为，他正是法律旨在保护的那种案件。至少，这是一个值得在法官面前听证以理清是非的案件。
He never got to do that, though, because our government decided to sweep up all kinds of people-- some with weak cases, some with strong cases-- put them all in detention and leave them to figure out the legal process from there. So David's case went down the way the administration seems to want. It was decided quickly, and he was deported right away. The whole thing took about three weeks, but it only went so fast because we skipped the part where he got due process. This is what our new immigration system is starting to look like right now. This is what it's becoming.
但他从未获得那个机会，因为我们的政府决定横扫各类人——有些案件较弱，有些案件很强——把他们全部拘留，让他们从那里自己去弄清楚法律程序。所以大卫的案件正如政府似乎想要的那样发展。很快就被决定了，他被直接驱逐出境。整个过程大约花了三周，但之所以这么快，是因为我们跳过了他获得正当程序的那部分。这就是我们的新移民系统现在开始看起来的样子。这就是它正在变成的样子。
Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show. David, by the way, is now part of a lawsuit against the federal government about these courthouse detentions and due process. Just today, as we're finishing the show that you're listening to right now, we heard that five more judges got fired.
纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的制作人之一。顺便说一下，大卫现在是起诉联邦政府关于这些法院拘留和正当程序的诉讼案的一部分。就在今天，当我们结束你正在收听的节目时，我们听说又有五名法官被解雇了。
Well, our program was reported and produced today by Nadia Reiman and Zoe Chace, with help from Angela Gervasi, who was edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put together today's show include Michael Comite, Suzanne Garber, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Tobin low, Katherine Rae Mando, Steve Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Alyssa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Kevin Gregg from Kurtzban Kurtzban Tetzeli and Pratt, Lindsey Gauzza, Cheryl David, Allison Cutler, Benjamin Remy, Jeremy deVine, Dana Leigh Marks, Elizabeth Young, Matt O'Brien, Brian Lonergan, RJ Hauman, Britney Dickerson, Jacob Martinez, Kristin Kepplinger, Lauren Kostes, and Heather Betz from the New York Legal Assistance Group, Aaron Reichlin-Melnick, Joseph Gunther, Caitlin Patler, Mary Georgevich and the National Immigrant Justice Center. Also thanks to all the other former immigration judges who talked to us about the court.
嗯，我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼和佐伊·切斯报道并制作，得到了安吉拉·格瓦西的帮助，由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑。今天制作节目的成员包括迈克尔·科米特、苏珊·加伯、卡西·霍利、塞思·林德、托宾·洛、凯瑟琳·雷·曼多、史蒂夫·尼尔森、瑞安·鲁梅瑞、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和黛安·吴。我们的管理编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢来自Kurtzban Kurtzban Tetzeli and Pratt的凯文·格雷格，林赛·高扎，谢丽尔·大卫，艾莉森·卡特勒，本杰明·雷米，杰里米·德维恩，达娜·利·马克斯，伊丽莎白·杨，马特·奥布莱恩，布莱恩·洛纳根，RJ·豪曼，布兰妮·迪克森，雅各布·马丁内斯，克里斯汀·凯普林格，劳伦·科斯特斯，以及来自纽约法律援助小组的希瑟·贝茨，亚伦·赖希林-梅尔尼克，约瑟夫·冈瑟，凯特琳·帕特勒，玛丽·乔治维奇和国家移民司法中心。也感谢所有其他跟我们谈论法庭的前移民法官。
A reminder that if you sign up to be a Life Partner with our program, you get ad-free listening. You get bonus episodes, and you get an archive of over 250 greatest hits episodes right in your podcast feed. So anytime you need something to listen to, there's something good right there.
提醒一下，如果你注册成为我们节目的生活合作伙伴，你将获得无广告收听体验。你将获得额外剧集，并能在你的播客订阅源中直接获得超过250集精选回顾。所以任何时候你想听点什么，都有好东西在那儿等着。
And of course, by becoming a Life Partner, you're helping us keep making this show, doing projects like this one where we're calling judges for months and months. To sign up, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
当然，通过成为生活合作伙伴，你正在帮助我们继续制作这个节目，进行像这样一个项目，我们连续几个月打电话给法官。如需注册，请访问thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交流中心）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. There was a farmer had a dog And Torey knows his name-o.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。有一个农民养了一条狗，托里知道它的名字。
Bingo. Bingo.
宾果。宾果。
I'm Ira Glass, Back, next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。